I was I was actually having a play with
a chat GPT the other day yeah uh which
is like the newest kind of like AI opens
I don't know if it's open source but
it's like available to the public right
yeah um and it's basically by open AI
which is a company that was founded by
Elon Musk so you know you know the
megalomania
the real-life Batman villain Elon Musk
yeah uh it is scarily good it was it is
actually kind of terrifying and well you
know when I when you say that I think
back to it and I think about all the
videos I've watched where there's Skyrim
NPC Behavior I think are we really that
hard to emulate I don't think we're that
hard to emulate we're pretty [__] for
yourself
I IQ person yeah life is meaning I I
mean like as a record is it hard to seem
somewhat human if you you know feed it
enough books and [__] well well I mean
isn't that the whole point of like the
touring test yeah yeah like well I mean
we're all like by the way I would like
to talk about kids programming as well I
completely unrelated to my Google search
wait what that was one of the
recommended topics for a podcast kids
programming kids programs I was in the
absolute State the absolute [__]
state of kids programs please indulge Us
in what I'm sorry the state of kids I
don't watch YouTube kids actually thank
you very much I get pissed off on
YouTube when it tells me it's a kid so
I'm like this it's clearly not for kids
myself hold on pause was that really the
top oh that was one cup yeah so here's
what they recommended talking no I I
know the top podcaster q a is fortnite
actually overrated
podcast topic ideas uh q a so we should
do that questions and answers ask me a
question yeah okay I'll ask you a
question sure our entire podcast is a
question isn't that paranormal do you
have good questions no we've done we've
done paranoids we've done paranormal
True Crime we spoke about that yeah
personal finance I'm not good at it
personal finance what a riveting topic
we should do this one guided meditations
I think we should do that what do you
mean like we should guide the viewers
how to meditate
do you meditate [__] no
I don't have to be a a singer to judge
singing right I was probably the only
person here that has actually meditated
yeah it's not that hard
um
kids programming time specific and
finally event planning event planning
event planning that sounds like a job
event planning guys I love I heck in
love planning events I just I just want
to plan events like birthday parties I
feel like that list was put together by
someone who's never done or watched a
podcast again so that was probably
written by a human being it was probably
written by Ai and like the AI would
probably make more interesting AI topics
probably yeah so is it really that hard
to emulate human beings I don't know I
guess we'll test it out oh no future
yeah I guess we'll test out on a future
episode but no like I was playing around
with Chad GPT yeah
um and like I think the people I you
know because our entire [__] uh lives
are now run by AI simply because I you
know started looking into chap gbt now
my my entire recommended on YouTube is
all child GPT just because that's what
YouTube thinks that our AI is
yeah and it's actually like terrifying
for
I think programmers right now software
Engineers like the amount like charge
EPT as a resource not just like it's
it's kind of like an all-encompassing a
AI you can ask it like scarily uh
scarily like human questions and it will
like literally type out an entire essay
it can do your homework for you yeah if
if you are if you if you type out like
the right prompts and everything like
that I tested it out
and I I typed in Tyler can you write a
gig Up Style review of Full Metal
Alchemist right and uh that that is that
is around 10 minutes long right right
and at first the first iteration it
types it out and it's like a kind of
like generic review and then I was like
oh try adding like a few jokes here and
there try referring to this try
referring to that it's it's
actually [__] freaked me out right
because it started adding jokes you know
like if you're familiar with my content
sometimes I do like little skits where
like some guy shouts in the background
and stuff like that chargpt added that
to the script I was like what the actual
[__] this is my my job is done my job is
actually done like it's this if if an AI
can like take my style of videos and
emulate it in the most basic sense now
What's it gonna be like [__] five ten
years in the future I uh yeah because I
I also I also did the same thing I think
the video should be out by it now but
like I decided to do a [__] pose video
on my second Channel where I did a
chainsaw man anime review but the entire
script is written by AI yeah but like I
didn't use the one you use I used a
couple of the other like kind of free to
use um opens I guess they're open source
the amount of stuff I've seen online I
was like this this gotta be free yeah a
lot of them though you have to pay like
a monthly subscription to use like what
the [__] using AI that much I don't know
but like the ones that I chose uh to use
what like kind of made like the first
like you know a couple of thousand words
will like yeah use like a test kind of
thing and then if you wanted to use like
unlimited words for however long it's
like five dollars a month or something
like that and I'm like first of all I'm
not paying for a subscription service
for an AI like [__] that so I just like
use the limit for the free to use to
just be like uh just yeah all I did was
just like chainsaw man anime review yeah
and then put in a couple of like
character things and like yeah they
clearly didn't know what chainsaw man
was I thought it was a man who was a
change yeah because because he tried to
write like a like a synopsis for it and
it was like uh Jeff is a man who owns a
chainsaw shop uh and he comes home one
day to kill his wife and he becomes the
chainsaw man but I just become yeah but
I just uh but I was like I thought that
was really funny so I just completely
left it as if and then I just read the
script verbatim yeah in like my style
um I don't know how it's turned out
because it hasn't come out as this video
comes out but it was really funny
because like man I thought I was like
contrarian and Posh on anime this AI had
no chill it was just like it was just
like yes uh the animation was a kind of
subpar but the fighting scenes were kind
of good but overall the story was very
forgettable and Bland I was like damn
hey I chill oh my God you should give
chaji PT a try because it's it's got it
it like writes things to a point where
you could literally take this
um like if we had Chad gbt when I was in
high school I was never doing any
[__] I would not be doing any [__]
homework it's yeah it literally gets to
a point where you could ask it to write
you know you could literally say write a
python script that does this and this
and like it understands what your
request is
entire codes of like you know like C
plus plus programming python whatever
the [__] you want or you can ask it to
write you a video script about X or Y
yeah yeah you can like ask it to iterate
upon itself to be like okay take this
script and add a little bit of humor add
a little bit of this maybe expand on
this section and it's it's [__] it's
it's an amazing amazing resources a
resource but at the same time it's
[__] terrifying teachers and
professors must be [__] sweating now
because you remember like I'm [__]
sweating because like remember like when
we were in college and like high school
and stuff like yeah a lot like the
biggest thing we had to worry about was
like don't take citations from Wikipedia
yeah like but now it's just like don't
get a [__] super you know like
hard-working AI to basically do your
work because like how do you there must
be measures nowadays right because like
this thing is so openly available to
like students now and it's like a lot
more well known it's probably only going
to be all well known from here on out
it's like how are they gonna figure out
a way to like make sure you're not just
using this AI right like they they
probably have to fight it I got it right
you build an AI to detect the AI
That's the only way I can like imagine
currently how they do it yeah
folks that's how they distinguished
we use the AI to kill
it's just it's just modern day weapons
yeah when you make a when you make a
tank that can withstand bullets then you
add Rockets
we're gonna make a stronger it's just
always going to be this cat of mouse
games
yeah but but like what's what's
incredible to me is like you know when
in school we learn about like you know
history and like you know the Industrial
Revolution and how all like the workers
kind of like revolted and like protested
when you know they were getting replaced
by machines yeah and you know you you
sit there as a kid being like huh dumb
history that'll never happen and we're
literally like seeing it happen right
[__] now yeah it's actually insane
the more that we become like NPCs the
more the NPCs become like humans right
have you not noticed the explosion of
NPC humor online have you noticed I have
noticed that yes
I've not noticed an explosion of NPC
humor it's something that's just existed
since yeah it's show big history online
Skyrim right yeah surely but it's like
more so like people behaving like NPCs
and like Tick Tock has just made it like
explode it's just so much so easy to get
like it's just America right well yeah
pretty much all of America right like
that's just clearly right we're
generalizing the entire America right
yeah we can go back to that it's
interesting it's interesting yeah it's
that whole thing of like the we live in
a simulation meme just kind of coming
back right I've seen the simulation is
failing right now yeah I've seen I've
seen so many memes like that just like
on Meme pages and like Tick Tock and
stuff like that of like oh we I was like
no we don't live in a simulation and
it's like oh really have you ever seen
your neighbor bring in the groceries and
it's like
what
I just love those music and they're just
like coming back from like these like
meme channels it's just pretty good
that's pretty good it's really good
that's just the next level of hit blunt
meme
you've seen my neighbors bring in the
groceries right I don't think like when
do they do it maybe I'm I'm the neighbor
okay yeah it just spawns in their fridge
obviously well to be fair I don't bring
the [__] groceries back because I
just ubereats all the time now so that
might be another big reason as well yeah